Graphs of f of t is equal to
the natural log of t plus 5,
and h of t is equal to 2e to
the t minus 1 are shown below.
So this is f of t
right over here.
This is h of t right over here.
Drag the variables to show which
equations they must satisfy.
There can be any number
of variables per category,
and some variables might
not go into any category.
So what are they talking about?
Well, we have all of
these variables here
and they want us to drag them
into different categories.
And if we look at
the actual graph,
we see that these
variables correspond
to either the t-
or the y-coordinate
for each of these
points that they've
picked out right over here.
And so we need to figure out if
you were to, for example, drag
this into this box,
that means you believe
that 2e to the t
sub 1 minus 1 is
equal to the natural
log of t sub 1 plus 5,
that this variable, if you
substitute it in for t,
that it's going to make
this equation true.
If, for example, you were
to substitute this y1 in,
that means that you think
2e to the y sub 1 minus 1
is equal to the natural
log of y sub 1 plus 5.
And so the three
different buckets
that they give us are
essentially setting the two
functions equal to each other,
setting 2e to the t minus 1,
which was h of t.
So this is essentially
setting h of t equaling 0,
and this is f of t equaling 0.
So let's take each
of them in turn,
and I copied and pasted
this onto my scratch pad
so that we can work
through the math.
So the first case that they had
was setting these two things
being equal to each other.
So what can we
substitute in for t
so that the natural
log of t plus 5
is equal to 2e to the t minus 1?
And that's another way of
saying for what values of t
is f of t-- this is another
way-- for what values of t
is f of t going to
be equal to h of t?
Well, two functions are equal
to each other at a given t
is, if you put that t in, they
both give you the same function
value.
They both give
you-- in this case,
if we say y is equal to f of
t and y is equal to h of t--
they'll both give
you the same y value.
So if when you input some
t in here to both of them,
so you input the same
t into both of them,
and if you get the same
output out of both of them,
that would correspond
to the same point.
So we're essentially saying,
where do these two functions
intersect each other?
And we see that they intersect
each other in two places.
There's this place over
here, where the coordinate
is t sub 5 comma y sub 5.
So you input t sub 5-- so this
is t sub 5 right over here--
you input t sub 5
into either function,
and you're going to get y sub 5.
Or another way of writing
this is, f is y sub 5
is equal to f of t sub 5, and y
sub 5 is equal to h of t sub 5.
You see that right over there.
Take t sub 5, evaluate
your function h.
There you get to y sub 5.
Evaluate your function f.
Or you could say that f of t
sub 5 is equal to h of t sub 5.
And I'm just writing it in a
million different ways-- not
a million different ways,
but a lot of different ways--
so that you get the idea.
And this is the same thing
as saying, of course,
that the natural log
of t sub 5 plus 1
is equal to 2e to
the t sub 5 minus 1.
So this is definitely
going to be true,
if t is equal to t sub 5.
So let me just make
sure that we-- so
let me write t sub 5 there.
So t sub 5 definitely
fits into this category.
You put t sub 5 in there,
then this is going to be true.
And then we have another point
where these two functions
intersect right over here.
If you input t sub 1 into
either function, t sub 1,
you get y sub 1.
So once again, same
exact logic, t sub 1.
This is also going to be true
if t is equal to t sub 1.
So this is also going
to be true for t sub 1.
So that first category we
could put t sub 5 and t sub 1.
Let make sure you can
see what I'm doing.
So that first category,
I could put t sub 1,
and I could put t sub 5.
Now, the next
category we're saying,
when does 2e to the t
power minus 1 is equal 0?
So let's give myself a
little bit more real estate.
So they're saying, when does--
let me draw a little line here,
because it's the next category--
when does 2e to the t minus 1
equal 0?
Which is another way of saying,
when does h of t equal 0?
And so if h of t is equal
to 0, and if we're saying
and if we're applying
the function of 8y
is equal to h of
t, or essentially
when does y equal
h of t equal 0?
Or another way of saying this,
when does h of t intersect
the horizontal axis?
When is that graph
not above or below it?
Our y value here is 0.
Well, h of t is the blue graph.
It intercepts the
t-axis right over here.
t-axis right over there.
We see that h of t
sub 3 is equal to y
sub 3, which is equal to 0.
Or actually, I could even
write it this way. h of t sub 3
is equal to 2e to
the t sub 3 minus 1--
that's just from the
definition of h of t--
and that we know that's
going to be equal to y sub
3, which is equal to 0. y
sub 3 is clearly equal to 0.
We're clearly intersecting
the t-axis there.
So t sub 3 would fall
into that second bucket.
And that's the only place
where on the graph of h of t
where it intersects the t-axis.
So t sub 3 is the only variable
I would throw into that bucket.
So let's do that.
So I would throw t sub
3 into this bucket.
And then the last bucket,
we're doing the same thing now
for f of t.
So f of t is the
natural log of t plus 5,
when does that
intersect the t-axis?
So this is f of t
right over here.
We clearly see right at
this point, f of t sub 2
is equal to the
natural log of t sub 2
plus 5, which is equal to y
sub 2, which is equal to 0.
So that last bucket, this
thing, natural log of t plus 5
is equal to 0-- this
was that last bucket--
this is going to be true for
when t is equal to t sub 2.
So we could throw a t sub
2 in that last bucket.
So let's do that. t sub 2 has
to go into that last bucket.
And we are done.
These other ones we
are not going to use.
I mean the rest
of them, these are
the y values that
the functions take on
at those different points.
And t sub 4, t sub 4
is kind of interesting.
t sub 4 is actually
clearly equal to 0,
because that's when we
intersect the y-axis.
So it's an interesting point,
but not one of the points
that would satisfy
those buckets.
And now we can check our
answer, and we got it right.